look I spent half of last year creating
an algorithm that trolls dating apps for
the best candidates and downloads them
into an Excel spreadsheet so
I know what I'm looking for that's not
weird at all
not at all that's one dating strategy
from the movie How to be single a new
Pew research study says this that 42
percent of adults believe online dating
is made finding a long-term partner
easier but Americans are still split on
whether it's safe way to meet people
you've heard the horror stories but
you've also heard the gazillion success
stories too the popular dating app
Bumble puts women in charge of making
the first move by sending a message to a
match after launching back in 2014 it
has more than 100 million users
worldwide wow is Right Nate the platform
just released its Financial results for
2022 and revenue was up nearly 19
percent to more than 903 million dollars
Bumble founder who's the genius behind
all this this is CEO Whitney wolf
Hershey is the youngest female CEO of a
publicly traded company I'm happy to say
she's 33 I like it she joins us for her
first interview after the company's 2022
earnings report
hey Whitney congratulations in Bravo you
must be floating today thank you you're
both just so happy to be here no we're
so glad you're here revenue is up 19
we've seen all the layoffs in businesses
and major companies that have had a lot
of layoffs that seems to have eluded you
why I think you know we're in the
business of love and the demand for love
and the need for connection on a global
scale gives us a great foundation for
our business and then when you layer
that with our team's commitment to
safety and authenticity and really
putting women at the center of the
experience and really you know building
what they want I think that has given us
great Runway but for the first time
you've appointed a general manager and I
thought oh does this mean Whitney's
stepping back is she taking a lighter
role in the company and you said no no
definitely not stepping back not a
lighter role we are so thrilled to have
drenna join us she's extraordinary this
gives me more time to actually lean in
to the areas that I am super passionate
about and add the most value so really
focusing on our product and safety and
Engineering a more accountable Way
Forward and thinking about gen Z and
women in general but also public policy
and really all of our brand efforts so
I'll be definitely very involved across
the board dating app safety is something
that at the top of the mind for users
and I'm pretty sure for you as well and
a lot of people are saying they would
like background checks before people
create these profiles that they get lost
in what is Bumble doing to help make the
experience safer absolutely so we have a
lot of features already that really show
that somebody is who they say they are
we were first to have photo verification
for example but we can do more and
that's what 2023 is about so part of me
leaning in a more on product is about
engineering more safety efforts and we
are coming out with a lot of exciting
features in 2023 part partnering with a
lot of really important initiatives that
do keep people safer so you know while
we are a very safe and trusted platform
right now there are of course ways to be
better all right let's talk about the
2023 hunt for love and connection yes
some survey numbers here uh about 39
almost 40 percent of users are on on
Bumble according to a survey you did
they just got out of a serious
relationship that's interesting okay
they're single again ready to mingle and
about a third of people are using dating
apps for the very first time could be an
overlapping group what are those numbers
and other things you know tell us about
the state of the online or app-based
dating World in 2023 yeah so there is no
shortage of demand for love and what's
really interesting is love does not have
to be just romantic and that's why we're
so excited about our platonic offering
this is about self-love this is about
friendship the BFF setting Bumble BFF
BFF so what's amazing is while people
are definitely getting back out there on
a romantic footing they do want to find
Love sometimes you need a break
sometimes you go through a breakup and
you need a pause and that's why we have
this incredible offering to find Friends
Community someone to go grab a bite to
eat with or go do yoga with and so we're
very excited about what 2023 has in
store and the normalcy of this I say I
got enough friends but but this is what
I'm fascinating About You Whitney you
started this company with 24 25. you
certainly didn't think I want to be a
billionaire when you first started what
were you thinking I mean and you seem to
have made the generational turn too in
this company mostly gen Z now it is it
was Millennials in the beginning so when
I started the company I was 25 and I was
was very distraught about what life was
like for myself my friend you were
singing around me well actually funny
enough I was actually with Michael my
now husband but I had so many
experiences as this young woman being
dissatisfied with what dating was like
in the world and why could a woman not
go first why couldn't we text first it's
a race not to do that exactly and I felt
that was backwards and then if you
looked at the online dating landscape
the same rules applied so I wanted to
really turn that on its head and create
a safer and Better Way well you have
done that one of the crew guys Jared
said it but is she happy
Whitney thank you so much we appreciate
it thank you